i got to say i love the game of thrones
reference i kind of had like a laugh out
loud moment because i thought it was
just like so perfectly positioned in
there
but how much have you resigned yourself
to always being so closely
associated to this iconic series that
you were a part of
i i'm i think the journey with that is
coming to terms with the fact that i
will be
and being proud of that you know i think
that there was a part of me that
fought against it for a long time it's
great to see you today
and it was so great to see you pop up in
season two of modern love i
really enjoy the series so it's happy to
see it come back for a second season and
then of course we've got an episode with
you and miss lucy boyton and the episode
is
so sweet it's dreamy it's funny
but how did you feel about having the
chance to show off your tinder side
mister
i it's one of the reasons i did it
rachel
i spent a long time looking very upset
about things
on on tv uh and for this i thought
you know what this is a nice chance to
do something softer and
sweeter and all those things you just
listed with a great
actress in lucy boynton and
it happened at a time when you know my
uh my wife just found out she was
pregnant and i got this through and they
just
really appealed to my rematch from my
romantic side
and um so yeah for those reasons i went
up and did a soccer rom-com
but it's it's intelligent as well that's
the other thing that's right
it is and it also like makes light of
obviously there's been a lot of
devastation in the past year plus but
you know poking fun of elements of the
pandemic and then also
love and trying to find love and in this
crazy world right now
so you said showing off your romantic
side just how romantic
are you mr kitt oh
you'd have to ask rose um do you know
what it's nice like you
this this gave me an opportunity to sort
of step into a
maybe a past self that might have met a
girl on the train at some point and sort
of
kind of had a chat and flirted and
all of that stuff that's one of the
great things you get to do as an actor
you get to pretend
you're something that you maybe
you know not but i'm i'm i'm a romantic
person
i think yeah always happy how are you
going to contact this woman we arranged
to meet on the train
two weeks from now she's never gonna
show do you love to watch a rom-com as
well i mean i'm
picking up some like sleepless in
seattle vibes with this episode a little
bit
yeah i'd love to watch a rom-com with
rose at all a little date night action
with your lady
i love one of my favorite films is when
harry met sally
you know i think that's one of the best
films full stop
there is and that's that's a rom-com and
so
yeah that i do like i do like a rom-com
it's not my
you know it's not a genre that i thought
i would necessarily
lean towards i i sort of did this
um there were other reasons i did this
because it raises some really
interesting questions about the pandemic
and also it becomes this little chamber
piece that i think
you know eventually when we look back at
this time this captures something that
might
say something about the pandemic you
know that that little period before
we all went into lockdown when no one
knew what the hell was going on
yeah what made choices that they could
never know that we would still be
working through this a year and a year
and a half two years later so
there was real kind of like there was i
wouldn't want to do something just for
fluff
it was it had some some depth to it it
sure did and i gotta say i love the game
of thrones reference i kind of had like
a laugh out loud moment because i
thought it was just like so perfectly
positioned in there
but how much have you resigned yourself
to always being so closely
associated to this iconic series that
you were a part of
i i'm i think the the journey with that
is coming to terms with the fact that i
will be
and being proud of that you know i think
that there was a part of me that
fought against it for a long time and
the process since finishing
has been about um being proud of the job
we did
being proud of that show being proud of
the character that i created
owning it and knowing that every time it
comes up in a
interview or in press that it's a good
thing what about everyone else
all the other people who think they know
what's good
[Music]
they don't get to choose yeah it totally
is i mean dude you even have your own
slot machines in vegas now
i know i saw those that tick tock go
around that was pretty funny of your
reaction
when you realized that your deal didn't
include merchandising rights
um you actually met rose on got so what
do you remember most about
first encountering her on set was
it you know this is kind of this piece
and modern love is all about that right
this piece specifically is about two
people meeting for the first time i
remember
i got it we were saying the other day it
was ten years ago with that you know and
i think that there's something about
meeting someone in your early twenties
where you just know it's right that's
absolutely terrifying
but you you go oh god what are we gonna
do now we've met each other very young
um and then you run away from each other
for a while because you're like surely
we can't have met each other this year
so um i just remember that feeling of
i'm in trouble here yeah but look where
the two of you are now with a beautiful
boy
and congratulations on that front how do
you feel
fatherhood has changed you most kid well
this bit doing this piece is probably
part of it i
it's it's definitely softened a part of
me
it is also um
taught me to look outwards a bit
you know i i i think all actors have a
tendency we have to really a tendency of
being a little bit egocentric
of kind of being a little bit
self-obsessed um
because our art and our work is is
a projection and a part of ourselves now
having a kid
um changes that somewhat because
you sort of at the end of the day you're
like well i have this child to get back
to you so it doesn't really matter
all that much i just need to look after
my boy
and i think that's where i'm i'm at the
moment and i'm i'm loving that kind of
freedom that's giving me and
um it's made me put less pressure on
myself
um more pressure on myself as a new
father less pressure on myself as an
actor
all right well it's been great chatting
with you today and i look forward to
what's next
doing a little uh indie movie at the
moment in upstate new york and then
another
series after this so things are busying
up and i'm doing a play
early next year so fantastic in
stateside or over the pond
london uh the the donmar theater i'm
gonna be henry the fifth
oh wonderful congratulations skit all
the success to you continued success
take care buddy
thanks rachel